[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN WICKE: So Dan
mentioned that things
will be tweeted out.
If you want to tweet something,
use TFDevSummit and people
can see it.
A quick shout-out
to all the people
who've joined us in viewing
parties all around the world,
literally.
It's awesome to
have you all here.
And of course, with
the live stream,
that's not limited
to physical presence.
OK, I think I'm all set up.
Thanks very much.
I'm Martin Wicke.
I'm going to talk
about high-level APIs,
and so really--
why would you do that?
TensorFlow is perfect.
Well, so shortly after we
released TensorFlow, really,
it got a lot of nice reviews.
And then some of
the things people
said, well, it's
really low level.
And this is my favorite
quote about this.
The first thing you
realize about TensorFlow--
it's a really low-level
library, meaning you'll
be multiplying
matrices and vectors.
Now, there's nothing
wrong with multiplying
matrices and vectors.
In fact, it is one of
TensorFlow's great strengths
that you can do this
at a very low level.
It allows us to
be very flexible.
You can easily combine
TensorFlow operators to create
any algorithm you can think of.
Because they're at
a very low level,
you don't have to fit
them together awkwardly.
It's very clear
what a matmul does.
It will always be a matmul.
It's used in many
algorithms, so you can just
use it to do whatever you want.
It's also extensible,
so you can recombine
these small little packets
of code in arbitrary ways.
And then you can
create a new algorithm
without having to change core
TensorFlow, which is great.
And so a lot of,
actually, our Python API
is built that way, where we have
taken the op kernels or the ops
and combined them
simply in Python
to create new functionality.
And as you will see, we'll
use those extensively
to make high-level APIs.
It's also maintainable.
So have some history with
this at Google, obviously.
And other people have probably
experienced this as well.
If you have large,
fused operations,
they accumulate features.
And as they accumulate
features, they accumulate crud,
and things go out of
fashion, and you end up
with these large,
unwieldy pieces.
And so we avoid that
completely by having
these small operations
that are really timeless.
Nothing much was going
to change to a matmul.
It's always going to be a
matmul, so that's great.
However, of course, this
also has disadvantages.
And it has
disadvantages for users.
And one of them is that we
lack higher-level primitives
in core TensorFlow if we only
stay at this very low level.
And we may have all the tools
you need to build your model,
but you may be working at a
level of abstraction that's
actually not suitable
for the kind of thinking
that you're doing.
And then also, we cannot
really publish out-of-the-box
algorithms this way.
And this is why we are
building a high-level API
for TensorFlow.
So starting in 1.0, we're
creating this high-level API.
We're building
this API by taking
components that have been built
over time by other people.
Now, the idea of
building high-level APIs
on top of TensorFlow is
not particularly novel.
So lots of people have done it.
Much of that has
happened in contrib,
in our contrib
part of TensorFlow.
So there's been
tf.contrib.learn,
tf.contrib.slim,
SKFlow, which is
integrated in tf.contrib.learn.
And we're taking
the pieces of those
and making a fully
supported, high-level API
inside of core TensorFlow.
Now, what that
should give you is
you will be able
to iterate faster,
over model architectures
or in general, things
that you may want to
build with TensorFlow.
Those higher-level
abstractions will
allow us to encode
best practices for you,
so it's harder for
you to make mistakes.
And we'll be able to
provide primitives
that will make it really easy
for you to write code that's
scalable right out
the door, and you
don't have to re-engineer
it once you realize,
oh, a single machine
is not enough
or a single GPU is not enough.
And then finally,
we'll prepare all
of this code to make it
really easy for you to deploy.
So at the level of abstraction
that we'll be talking about,
you'll be able to say, OK,
export this to serving.
And you'll hear a
whole talk about how
to serve models later.
Export this to serving,
and it will just work.
That is just a promise.
So how do we do this?
So you've seen this before.
Rajat's talked about it.
This is a very
popular illustration,
and what we're doing
is, on the bottom,
you have TensorFlow that
you know about-- the op
kernels, the TensorFlow
engine, and then the front
ends that you're
typically dealing with.
And all of the things that I'm
going to be talking about today
are built on the
Python front end.
So the first step is to build
a higher level of abstraction
for building models,
and we call this layers.
It is modeled after
neural network layers,
but it's not limited to
neural networks, necessarily--
and basically,
larger pieces of code
that are grouped together
in sensible ways.
And on top of that,
we offer Estimator,
which is a class that
streamlines all of the things
that you have to do in order
to actually train and evaluate
a model, which is
most of the work.
The actual model
architecture is usually not
all that complicated.
And for simple
cases, you're also
going to be able to
use the Keras model.
And again, there's
a talk directly
after this one about Keras.
And if you're
interested in Keras,
if you're a user of Keras,
you should definitely
wait for that.
There's going to be
a lot more detail.
So for simple cases, you
can use a Keras model.
The estimator is a little more
production-oriented or for more
complex cases.
And then finally, we have
now this estimator interface,
which is nice.
And we can offer you models
that are completely built out
of the box, ready to go.
And there's a number of talks
in the afternoon that actually
will talk about what kind
of models are offered
and how they work.
OK, so let me start
by introducing layers.
So you've seen this before,
as well, in Dandelion's talk.
This is a convolutional
network that is used for--
well, this particular one, I
think, is used on [INAUDIBLE].
This is written down
in a way that you may
see it written down in a paper.
This could be an
illustration in a paper,
except for the color scheme.
And our goal would be that you
can write this network down
in code, without switching
levels of abstraction here.
So I want each of these
layers in the neural network
to be represented with a
single function in my code.
So if I have a
convolutional layer,
I want there to be a
convolutional layer function
that does the same
thing, conceptually,
and that I can just
use and replace
my illustration with some code.
So if I have a
convolution layer,
a convolution function,
if I have a pooling layer,
I make a pooling function, and
so on, and so on, and so on.
I've added dropout.
That's the only
difference to the one
that you've seen
earlier, I think,
because dropout is better.
OK, so now, if you write your
models this way, what happens
is that you avoid a whole
lot of cognitive load.
You don't have to worry
so much about, oh, I
have to make variables.
I have to call this function,
that function, reshape.
All of this is done for you,
and there's a lot of things
that you probably
wouldn't have done
if you wrote it from scratch
that are really useful to have.
So again, you will be able
to iterate much faster
using this type of working.
And then we introduce, or we
encode these best practices
for you.
And a big one is scoping.
So you've seen that the graph
visualizer actually uses scopes
to group nodes in
the graph together,
so it's easier to get an
overview over big networks.
All of that is done for
you if you use layers,
so each layer will show
up as a little box.
And only if you want to
inspect the actual going
on inside, which you probably
don't, you have to move in.
All the layers support
variable batch size.
So once you move
it to serving, you
don't have to re-engineer your
model because suddenly you
don't have a batch size of 32.
You have a batch size of 1.
All these kind of things are
things that are easy to forget,
but we do them for
you, so it's OK.
I want to mention that
all of these layers
are compatible with Keras.
So if you use one of
these functional layers,
that is in fact equivalent.
In fact, the implementation
is shared to saying,
use a dense layer object
that is in Keras style,
and apply it to the same inputs.
And you'll hear about
this in the next talk,
but soon we'll be
able to-- we'll
have a Keras module
that is just completely
compatible with the Keras API.
And Francois will talk about
this in much more detail,
so I'll leave it alone.
OK, so this now makes it
really easy to build models.
But models are really only a
small part of the total effort.
And the real effort is
getting them to train,
and they maybe getting them to
train in a distributed manner.
And that's what
Estimator is for.
Estimator is an interface
to abstract away
what the actual
implementation looks like.
So to start, let's
consider a generic model.
Any model, any machine
learning model,
will look somewhat like this.
You'll have some
inputs, possibly labels
if it's supervised learning.
There's some sort of model,
and it produces predictions.
Now, if that is
trainable, then this
looks a little bit different,
where instead of predictions,
you can also produce some
sort of training operations.
Often, this training operation
is built on the predictions,
but it's not necessarily so.
And in TensorFlow
land, what that
looks like is that
you have a train
op that you call in the loop.
And each time you call
it in loop, probably,
it's going to feed a mini
batch or absorb a mini batch
and then update the weights
of the model somehow.
And we're not going to take a
position on what that op looks
like exactly, but
it exists, and it's
going to be run in the loop.
Of course, if you're
doing machine learning,
you also want to evaluate.
And while for small
or for simple cases,
you can use the predictions
to evaluate and just
feed some test data into
it, in more general cases
it's very useful to have a
separate evaluation graph
or evaluation op that produces
your evaluation metrics.
And again, because your
evaluation data set may not
fit in memory, you want
to run this in a loop
and feed it mini batches.
So basically, what
we're saying here
for Estimator is that every
model looks like this.
And so we draw a box around
it, and we call it Estimator.
And Estimator is really going to
be configured using this Model
function, which effectively
contains the code that you have
written anyway, which produces
this training op, this eval op,
these predictions.
But it's just a single function.
You pass it to
Estimator, and then
what you get in return is an
interface that always stays
the same, and that you can
write downstream infrastructure
against, and that takes away
some of the work that you would
otherwise have to do
manually and every time you
have the model.
So in particular,
it encapsulates
all the information and
all the necessary code
about sessions and graphs, and
it has the loops inside of it
so that you don't
have to write them.
Writing these loops
properly is error prone,
and by using an estimator, you
don't have to worry about this.
You worry about what you
actually care about, which
is the details of your model.
So there's one more
thing that we added,
which makes sense only in the
context of TensorFlow, which
is that you can export your
model to a saved model, which
is a data format that is
directly usable in TensorFlow
Serving, which you'll
hear about later.
OK, so this, again, it
encodes best practices.
It deals with
end-of-input exceptions.
It deals with workers going
down in disputed setting.
It produces the right
summaries at the right time,
all these things.
You can easily
deploy it to serving
by simply calling
the Export-Save model
and using that save model
on the model server.
And it's scalable by design.
So what you get for free
here is, if you have a model
that you can distribute
using data parallelism,
this will simply work, and you
won't have to worry about it.
So now I will tell you about
some models that we have built.
And I won't tell you
about the details.
You'll hear more about
that in the afternoon.
And I won't bore you
with more diagrams,
but let's just see some code.
So here is a more
or less complete
piece of code that lets
you write a linear model.
It's a very simple
model, linear model.
And you see the class name here
is Linear Regressor, so that is
one of our canned estimators.
It is an estimator in
the is-instance sense,
but it has a slightly
different interface.
Or it has the same interface,
but it has a slightly different
constructor.
The only thing I have to
tell this estimator is,
what imports do you want or
do I want you to work on?
And for this, we have made
this declarative language
to specify input data,
which is Feature columns.
And here in this
example, I just say,
well, this model expects
a thing called Area
is going to be a real number.
And if you were to
parse it out of an input
stream of some sort, let's
say a TF example, the field
it has in there is square foot.
Then there is another real
number, and it comes--
the name is numrooms.
And then there is an
integerize feature,
which is really a string
that I treat as an integer.
And I know that it's never
going to be higher than 100,000.
That's a zip code.
Now, the feature integerization
is a little bit--
it's not entirely
straightforward
if you want to do it yourself.
So you can think of this as a
one-hot vector that comes in,
although it's not implemented
that way because that
would be terribly inefficient.
But again, you don't really
have to worry about that.
So now, all I need to do is--
I already have an
estimator here,
so I just have to call
[INAUDIBLE] and predict on it.
The interface always
stays the same,
which is nice because
if I want to experiment
with different
ones, I can simply
say, oh, let me swap that out.
Instead of a linear model,
I want a DNN model, so
a Dense Neural Network.
And then all I have to do
is change the class name.
And this is a more
complex model, so it has,
actually, some hyper-parameters.
And in this case, I
can say, oh, how many
units or how many layers
do I want in this model?
And how many units
should they have?
And otherwise, it
really stays the same.
The only difference
here-- and it's
worth pointing out that
dense neural networks really
don't like getting
integerized features directly
or large one-hot
features directly.
So instead, I'm
going to embed this.
And again, using this
nice declarative language
for input specification,
I can just
say, oh, make an
embedding column out
of this integerized feature,
and then we're done.
And this embeds it
into eight dimensions,
so it's very straightforward.
Now, all I have
to do is make sure
that the input
functions actually
produce features of that
name, and I'm good to go.
So really, the only
question that remains
is, when can I have it?
So right now with
1.0, which I think
should be released as of
right now or something--
I skipped the last 20
minutes of releasing this.
You have layers in core.
And the distinction
between core and contrib
is really-- in core,
things don't change.
Things are backwards
compatible until release 2.0,
and nobody's thinking
about that right now.
So if you have something
in core, it's stable.
You should use it.
If you have something in
contrib, the API may change.
And depending on your needs, you
may or may not want to use it.
So layers are in core.
They're stable.
Estimators and canned estimators
right now are still in contrib.
We anticipate that
we move Estimator--
the base Estimator, the custom
Estimator-- into core at 1.1.
Canned estimators will
still be in contrib,
and they will move
to core subsequently.
So in 1.2, we expect to
have some of them in,
and then there will be more,
and we'll keep building more.
And you'll hear about
it in the afternoon,
how many we have already.
Traditionally, these
roadmap-- these releases
have happened six to
eight weeks apart.
So that's kind of the
timeline you're looking at.
All right, and with
that, I am done.
And the next talk will be by
Francois, author of Keras,
about Keras.
[MUSIC PLAYING]